you are also recently spotted with Tom
Hanks does that mean that there's like
another Toy Story out there what's
happening oh
you know Tom and I uh really become very
close friends from Toy Story one he's a
very different person than me and he
eats off my plate which I remember that
I come from a family you don't do that
because you've got a lot of kids if I
ate it I wanted my so Tom's at the
middle of first Toy Story you go oh this
is just so much fun working with you and
I go those those are actually my French
fries that's why they're in this area
here he and I differ on so many things I
adore that man's heart and mind and so
now we're it it it's the most peculiar
lunches we've been going to lunch since
Toy Story one
you know twice two three times a year
and we're like two older women because
we will sit almost too close to each
other at a booth yeah it's just weird
and all of a sudden I go you know I
think I'm gonna get up and sit on that
side of the table and even Rita's asked
Tom says what do you guys talk about and
I don't think I've ever trusted a human
being as much as Tom to listen to me and
vice versa he he very different opinions
on so many things but he's gotten me to
accept his he's really a wonderful
engaging person and he's the first guy
that listens to me and doesn't judge and
we talk about I love that open
[Applause]
you progress and grow and learn about
other people's opinions and maybe yours
listen just learn to listen go and not
jump in as one one buddy don't [ __ ] on
people yeah you know what you should do
you know they don't throw in your
opinion just listen and be able to walk
away from that and go oh God I heard I
heard what somebody said yeah absolutely
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]